I always thought you were going to be
one of those guys that did those
independent movies that didn't make that
much money but now you're big time yeah
the movie did well and now everybody uh
thinks I'm a director so that's where
the opportunities are coming how did
your life change when you start when you
direct a movie that makes over 100
million dollars you get to uh honestly
the biggest thing is I'm getting to work
in Los Angeles where'd you shoot elf elf
most of it was in Canada all the
exteriors were in New York and anything
that's not showing a street was shot in
Vancouver so now how do you get that job
because that's a big Hollywood movie in
the first place also at the time that I
got it old school hadn't been out yet it
was like a low budget comedy High
concept comedy with a Saturday Night
Live guy Will Ferrell wasn't really uh
let me tell you some Oddity yet you got
that movie because nobody expected that
movie to make that kind of business
right that's exactly right right you
surprised everyone then well the first
thing that surprised everybody was old
school with Vince and will and and Luke
that did really well and that made
everybody think that you know will might
be a bankable star so new line got
behind elephant got excited about it how
much that movie cost to make elf it was
like
in the in the 30s 30 something 30
something million yeah when a film makes
over 100 million dollars in Hollywood
that means you get offered every script
and and now so you said Stars probably
call you the other people are nicer to
me now so you said to them hey I want to
shoot all my movies in La I don't want
to leave home yeah I got small kids
who's the star of your new movie uh it's
two kids so there's no star really yeah
would you say you're doing the Robert
Rodriguez thing yes I would you know a
lot of people in my generation are now
we're not like the Indie guys anymore
link letter with the School of Rock
we're just getting old you're doing kids
movies we're doing movies because I'm
watching kids movies right I can't make
fast and the furious I can't make these
teenager movies and if you want to make
a movie with a budget for more than 20
million so yes you got to go for kids or
for teenagers John's The Happening guy
now what else happy but you know what
you're as good as your last movie as a
director that's right because it takes
you a year and a half two years to do it
and I'm gonna be the elf guy until the
next one comes out
thank you